et on va maintenant parler de musique
avec deux festivals qui se tiendront du
29 juin au 2 juillet le festival des
étoiles du classique est celui des
musiques anciennes on va commencer par
parler du festival Les Étoiles du cassis
avec vous Thomas Lefort vous en êtes le
directeur artistique alors qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve au programme de ce
festival alors le festival donc et
constitué de 12 concerts donc nous avons
une première partie au théâtre Alexandre
Dumas avec une grande soirée des étoiles
du classique présentée par Clément
Rochefort où l'on retrouvera la fine
fleur des jeunes talons de la musique
classique réunis ensemble et donc nous
offrons aussi un verre au public c'est
un concert très
convivial nous avons de l'opéra avec
l'opéra Foucault et une représentation
des Noces de Figaro le 30 juin au
théâtre Alexandre Dumas
et nous avons des concerts de musique de
chambre à la famille Moreau de jeunes
musiciens qui se retrouvent en famille
pour nous proposer un programme autour
de la musique centrale donc l'hame slave
et nous avons aussi des concerts de
jeunes publics puisque nous accueillons
au festival plus de 1000 enfants ni
scolaires qui sont invités au concert
donc sur deux concerts de jeunes publics
le carnaval des animaux de Saint-Saëns
et la boîte à mystère qui a lieu le
premier jour et après donc nous avons la
partie en plein air le 1er juillet dans
le parc du château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye où nous proposons
donc en clôture de ce de ce troisième
jour un concert symphonique avec
l'orchestre sinatto et quelques solistes
donc dans le parc de château avec une
sonorisation c'est un rendez-vous très
festif convivial on peut pique-niquer
dans le parc
et il y a une offre de restauration
c'est l'idée donc de ce festival et
d'aider les jeunes talents
mais se réunir autour de la musique
classique de proposer un nouveau format
un peu plus dynamique différent des
salles de concert et d'attirer du jeune
public à la musique classique et voilà
et donc c'est intéressant également
c'est que les étoiles du classique donc
forcément on pense aux danseuses étoiles
on pensait à la musique classique mais
il y a aussi un une présentation de
danse tango il y a aussi du jazz donc
finalement est-ce que l'idée c'est pas
de représenter un peu les grandes
familles de la musique
oui alors effectivement nous essayons de
en fait alors c'est toutou la musique
classique d'où les étoiles du classique
mais nous proposons des une ouverture
avec des concert jazz et donc de la
danse cette année alors dernière nous
avions pas dedans et cette année nous
avons décidé de proposer ça aussi et
donc time to dense qui est un concert le
2 juillet au parc toujours du château et
qui vous proposera de l'accordéon la
trompette du Lindy Hop dans ce jazz donc
voilà avec quelques quelques petites
surprises et justement pour faire la
promotion de votre festival vous avez
interrogé des artistes et on va
justement écouter un extrait d'Apolline
rail festival qui est une chanteuse
lyrique
[Musique]
alors cette chanteuse elle a 27 ans et
justement la particularité de ce
festival c'est que les artistes sont
tous
âgés de 18 ans à 30 ans pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez fait ce choix parce que
les jeunes artistes ont besoin d'être
soutenus alors je ne fais pas ça seul je
fais ça avec un mécène un des grands
mécènes du Conservatoire de Paris et
notre objectif est de les promouvoir et
de les voilà de les faire rencontrer
avec le grand public et donc pour eux
c'est essentiel et puis je pense pour le
public aussi de rencontrer des jeunes
musiciens
dans un cadre un peu différent de ce qui
existe
en plus c'est l'été donc j'imagine que
c'est beaucoup plus agréable de d'être
en plein air et profiter un peu d'un peu
de musique c'est un peu un événement
tremplin pour ces jeunes est-ce que
c'est difficile de faire carrière quand
on est jeune oui effectivement alors il
y a beaucoup de musiciens et donc mais
la difficulté vient aussi du fait que
il y a de l'offre mais il n'y a pas
assez de formats différents avec
beaucoup de de
différences et donc voilà et puis la
musique classique et malheureusement un
peu un sujet ta cliché encore et trop
souvent et là l'idée c'est d'oublier ses
clichés vous allez voir venez on est
sympa et puis en plus voilà on est
décontracté et c'est pas pareil que
vraiment que une salle de concert c'est
une expérience différente voilà donc
l'idée c'est aussi d'attirer un public
jeune oui bien sûr de leur faire
découvrir
et puis il y en a pour tous les goûts je
pense que on a on a on propose une large
palette de concerts et voilà donc en
plus le parc est magnifique et voilà
donc alors c'est votre deuxième édition
qu'est-ce qui change par rapport à la
première édition alors la première
édition c'est toujours un ballon d'essai
on a eu du succès puis on a eu 4000
personnes donc et ce qui n'a changé
c'est notamment le plein air c'est ce
qu'on a augmenté la partie planaire on a
rajouté un deuxième concert symphonique
puisqu'on en avait qu'un seul l'année
dernière et donc parce qu'ils sont très
appréciés par le public c'est vraiment
les rendez-vous les les plus marquants
du festival c'est deux grands concerts
symphoniques de cette année
et voilà donc moi aussi
un concert complet malheureusement qui
est le carnaval des animaux donc
n'hésitez pas à vous précipiter sur la
billetterie parce que voilà ça ça monte
assez vite alors si je peux permettre je
donnais quelques infos la billetterie
est ouverte donc sur notre site internet
les étoiles du classic.fr et sur place
au théâtre Alexandre Dumas donc à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye à partir du jeudi
donc jeudi vendredi de 13h à 17h et puis
la billetterie sera ouverte aussi en
plein air devant les grilles du château
de samedi le samedi et dimanche à partir
10h30 alors autour de la table est-ce
que la musique classique ça vous
intéresse Véronique oui comme ça des
cloisonnées un peu à la portée tous ça
donne vraiment très envie de voir